welcome and thank you for joining us
today for this lab Roots webinar our
topic today is leveraging the plant
genome to increase crop yield and
quality we have three outstanding
speakers for you today um GNE Bennett
from The genome analysis Center in the
UK Philip Roby from cooken Elma and
daresh parar from uh seed a wide variety
of seed company and agricultural
experience in India our format for
today's webinar is going to be that
we'll have all three presenters uh go
through their content we've set aside a
question and answer period at the end of
the session uh for those in our remote
audience the way to enter a question is
to use the blue question and answer box
that's in the lower leftand corner of
your environment enter your questions
there and then after the three
presentations uh I'll be happy to relay
those questions to our
presenters so our first presenter is
gain Bennett as I mentioned gain is uh
an automation specialist with the genome
analysis Center he's been working
extensively in uh the library
Construction Group where he works on
adapting and modifying NGS protocols um
for use with high through
automation Philip Philip Roby is a
Perkin Elmer principal scientist working
with the alpha technology at perk and
Elmer uh and dwares has had extensive
experience in crop science and
agriculture in India and will be our uh
third speaker um presenting from a
background of various uh experience in
biotechnology application as they apply
to crop science without further Ado I'm
going to pass the control over to our
first Speaker uh G Bennett and gain it's
your
show hello um as the uh as uh Rick said
my name is uh G Bennett I uh work for
the genome analysis Center orak as it's
um known as um uh I'm an auto automation
specialist and I basically um look at um
automating and implementing new
protocols and uh integrating them into
existing pipelines and develop new and
custom automation for various of the
sort of um research pipelines that we
are putting together at uh
Tek okay um I'm I'm going to talk today
about a uh uh a low input an inexpensive
sequencing pipeline we put together to
work with the weat genome and before I
do I'll just give you a little bit of uh
T teak background um so teak is a a
relatively young Institute we're about
um 5 years old we just celebrated our
fifth year uh our fifth birthday we're a
bbsrc funded Institute and we're located
on um Norwich Research Park in um
Norfolk in the UK and we're a kind of
technology and Innovative driven um
Institute focusing on um health and
security and animal plant and microbial
research
um as you can see from this next slide
we're not particularly fussy what kind
of um organism we work with we've worked
with many things over the um years
including um Ash dback and um uh the the
might that's been infecting the European
pollen bees and um we' worked with naked
mole rat um uh dog Mouse and uh of
course wheat and many other crops um
before I uh go into the main part of my
talk I just give you a quick tour of our
lab
um uh we have five alumina highs um one
is two high seek 2000 and four are um
High seek 2500s two of which have the
High um capacity uh terab terabyte
capacity run module and we also have
some aluminum mys we have a pack bio
we're also on the minion Access program
and we've also recently taken um charge
of a an a bionano iris which is a a
mapping
system um now on to the sort of more
interesting machines I work in library
construction I I work with liquid
handling machines and in our library
construction lab we have a whole Suite
of pack and Elma machines um we
initially I wasn't there when the
decision was made to go with pack and
Elma for our library construction but uh
um it came down to the fact that pelma
had a wider portfolio of methods that we
wanted to run and with hindsight I don't
think we could have got as far as we
have if we had hadn't bought these um
machines the very first for what we want
to do um we have three
Cyclones um these are liquid handling
machines these handle our routine
Library construction um anyone can
submit any sample in any state to us um
whether it's for sample QC or Library
construction or sequencing or primary
analysis or even further
analysis um you can do any one of those
we I also develop on these or me and my
group or the group that I'm in we
develop uh new and bespoke methods on
these we also have in our um QC lab uh a
zepha and a twister um the the zepha has
um was originally bought in to do sort
of various cleanups but it's kind of
become um does lots of sort of things in
the post PCR area like um um ampon
normalization and uh PCR clean up as I
said JX and Plate Reader said up it's
quite useful machine and also we um we
have various other QC machines we have a
GX and a lab chip
XT we also have an NGS Express for the
more smaller scale stuff sometimes
you've got a handful of libraries that
you don't want to set up a huge Cyclone
to do and there isn't anyone available
to do them so we can run these on our um
nggs Express and we have um sort of
various other things that we have
planned for that so on with the main um
part of my talk um sequencing the we
genome so why sequence week the
international week sequencing Consortium
got together um several years ago now to
to try and um uh generate a uh a high
quality reference for the bread wheat
genome it's the third most important um
crop in the world after rice and Maze
and um one of the it it's reference um
is not up to the same sort of quality as
rice and Maze I believe and uh and it's
thought that uh because food production
has to increase by 50% by the year two
2050 without the use of um uh expanding
land use or the use of fertilizers and
also that we thought that uh or it's
thought that if we can sequence The
genome to a high quality it will enable
um breeders to develop um higher
yielding varieties new varieties that
are better able to adapt to things like
climate change and and need um sort of
fewer fertilizers and um Pest Control
Etc however the problem with wheat is
the weat genome is
complicated um it it's very big it's
about five times the size SI of uh human
and
um bigger genomes tend to have um more
repetition and
um wheat is further Complicated by the
fact that it's a hexaploid and uh it has
three essentially three sub genomes that
are homologous to each other um each
genome has uh uh seven chromosomes and
the genome is not only um you know it's
a hexaploid but it's also it's very
highly repetitive and is um very GC Rich
so the international wheat sequencing
Consortium um simplified or part of it
part of the labs that were involved in
it simplified The genome by uh um
separating or sorting the chromosomes
into the uh individual chromosomes the
genomes into individual chromosomes uh
and sometimes into the chromosome
arms for us to work at them at teak we
needed to simplify them further
basically if you have a a chromosome you
have the same problem that you have with
the whole genome it's just it's a lot
smaller so we need to to simplify it
further and how we do this is using an
old um sort of tried and tested
technology from um uh sang sequencing
days uh uh I don't know if anyone
everyone's old enough to remember what a
back is a back is a bacterial artificial
chromosome essentially you take your
Genome of Interest or your Gene of
interest you cut it up into little bits
you insert each one of those little bits
into an ecoli grow it up overnight and
you have um many copies of your Gene to
um prep and sequence however just this
process alone will give you a lot of
redundancy you you'll have many many
copies of your Gene of Interest so the
process is then sent away or the library
is then sent away for further um
processing to create a minimal tile path
um this is just a minimum number of
backs that is required to get through a
particular um
sequence um for week 3dl which is the
part of the genome that Tac was working
with at this time um it is greater than
6,000 clones that's 6,000 libraries you
have to make and just to give you a bit
of perspective of how big um this task
is this is the um map of the chromosomes
that have been given out around the
world um and you can see here that uh
I'm pointing to 3dl which is the long
arm of the um third chromosome on the D
genome so there's a lot of work to be
done to get a good sequence um okay so
you've got got your liary you've got
your minimal tile path in in in
bacterial cultures you need to extract
the DNA so um we have a Tac we're lucky
enough to have two robotic platforms we
also have a Beckman culter machine which
we use um a modified Cosmic prep to
extract the DNA from uh back Library 384
um samples at a time and the process has
been um it's been developed to the
extent that it gives very um high
quality um back DNA at the end of it
however backs back inserts are varying
in sizes um some of the uh bacteria grow
slower than others so the yield can be
very very variable um and there is no
way we could normalize this to prepare
for Library um construction because um
it would take so much time and effort so
we kind of have to go with this sort of
spray of um concentrations and also
there'll be different sizes as well in
there so um our method is a sort of
quick and dirty method and um we're
going for I guess uh quantity more than
quality so the library construction is a
modified next protocol when we first
started um uh developing this method it
was a a next year was owned by epicenter
and we optimized it for that but then
alumina bought it out and um took it
over and modified the protocol so we've
changed it and we've changed it to the
extent that the only um uh the only
original part of the um uh aluminum
exterior protocol that we use is the
tagmentation enzyme every other reagent
has been replaced and we also because um
we knew there would be um much scope for
multiplexing you got to remember a back
um no matter how big it is and
complicated it is it's much smaller than
a a whole genome um our backs range from
about 75 KB to about 250 KB um so the
scope for multiplexing is great Darren
Heavens the senior research assist
assistant who was uh um I guess the
driving force behind this particular
pipeline he designed um 48 forward and
48 um reverse uh dual indexing barcode
so we had a capacity to do to pull
2,34 samples however we started off with
um uh 96 samples and um
uh to get the pipeline to uh 96x sorry
to get the pipeline going we we quickly
moved up to 34 but before I go further I
just want to divert into a little bit of
automation because this is the bit that
I'm really interested in the bit that I
do um just working with these kinds of
libraries is a a phenomenal um what's
job in logistics and this is uh one of
the things that stuck us for a long time
is the be based cleanup for the Post
tagmentation which um essentially so in
a 384 whee plate there was 20 micr
sample 20 micr of beads you displaced
about 30 of it if your tip went to the
the bottom but these had to be perfectly
mixed and with no air bubbles if any air
bubbles got in there they would kill the
back so um this picture here was the
first time I got it right um and uh uh I
always stick this picture in any talk
about the uh backs because it's uh yeah
this was for me breaking the back of
most of the automation was this bit um
so we have a a pool of uh libraries and
um we then use a pipin to uh Pippin
Preps sorry Sage pip and prep to uh size
select them and um they're cleaned up at
that point as a pool and um uh submitted
to the sequencer um for sequencing so
this is the uh results from the very
first uh plate that we ran um you can
see that even we were sort of
overwhelmed with the number of reads we
got with uh each back and you can see
that uh the coverage is quite a lot so
um uh we realized that we could there
was much much more scope than we
realized for um multiplexing and um we
were trying to aiming for 30X coverage
this sort of gave us a buffer for any
sort of small amounts of contamination
and and what have you and so we could
expand um the uh pooling even further to
2,36 or six times 384 libraries can't
remember exactly the uh number off the
top of my head so the assemblies look
like this so the um this is one of the
very first uh uh single back assemblies
that we we got together and you can see
where all the backs are aligning to um
each other but you can still see there's
a very high what we cons we believe to
be a high GC area or there's areas that
the sequencer can't seem to get through
so and I have to say it was at this
point here that I left the program I'm
an automation person and as soon as the
automation was finished I I moved on to
um uh pastures new to do other
um uh High throughput methods um but
Darren Heavens continued on he wanted to
improve the sequence even further he
wanted to put some scaffold sequence in
there so he chose a um oh sorry I've
skipped the slide so this is just some
statistics from the assembly um so at
this stage here um the
6,144 Clones that we were working with
um the average con was less than 18 and
and greater than um uh the n 50 was
greater than 13
KB okay it was this point I left Darren
went on to work on uh using a long made
pair protocol to try and put some
scaffold in if you don't know what long
may pair is basically cize a big
fragment of DNA and um where where it
joins at one end you take that out
that's your mate and um you know that
between those two sequences it's of a
given length and here you can see it's 6
to 8 KB Darren's strategy was uh very
interesting in that he just took the DNA
of the um straight from the back prep
and pulled it all together and did the
um uh long mate pair in a single
reaction and the theory is that that
each mate would only map to one back and
you just uh I guess what's the word uh
blast it back to the original back and
as you can see here again um there was
was much scope for um multiplexing and
he's got it to the point where he can do
12 * 384 well plates that's three and so
that's 12 Long make pair reactions
pulled together um down a high SE
claim okay so the longm pair data um
vastly improved what we had you can see
here there's a a number of graphs where
you can see that the number of conts has
has dropped and the uh assembly size has
uh got bigger and um I I put a note in
here the larger assembly sizes show
increased percentage of ends and we
believe that's because of the variation
between the two mates don't know if
we've quite got to the bottom of that
that perhaps some of those Ends don't
actually
exist okay to to show the the sort of
final improvements um the uh average
sort of scaffold um cont number has gone
down to less than seven and the average
scaffold um uh n50 has gone up to 90 KB
and this is kind of where the uh 3dl um
project is at the moment all the library
construction has um finished and uh for
the moment we may have to go back and do
some more depending on um uh what needs
to be done um as you can see it's sort
of Pretty in pretty good condition
there's a quarter of it um assembles to
a single um contig and that big spike at
11 that should say 11 plus um number of
conts per per per back um and now it's
with the bioinformaticians who just have
to stitch all this data together and try
and make a a a full 3dl sequence and
that's pretty much my um story so the
future for the back pipeline is that
Darren's going to publish um this work
and he's continuing to tweak it and he's
working other on other problem
chromosomes Bary 2 H and the zero H
which is the unclassified chromosomes
Lum which is a uh another grass and he's
looking to increase the capacity to 468
samples per Lane and he's also um
looking at running the long mate pair
pools down the same Lane
so yeah and that that I think that's
pretty amazing for me and the robots the
robots and I have moved on to a
pre-capture pooling Exon capture
pipeline um again greatly multiplexed
also to do with wheat but um uh a
completely different project I'm also
looking to do RNA seek in a day I've
heard some pretty good things about
lexogen and a high throughput uh pack
bio um process so uh that just leades me
to thank a few people I'd like to thank
think uh Matt Clark who was the
principal investigator um in this
project and he's also the head of plant
and microbial genomics Darren Heavens uh
senior research assistant and the
driving force behind you know the
development of the protocol and you know
the amount of hours we sat talking about
how high tips should be le cold my
longsuffering line manager um James and
Heather used to run the pipeline with us
and it took used to take four people
when it was in full swing full swing um
but we've sort of tweaked enough to the
extent that um uh only one person needs
to to run it now um I'd also like to
thank deali vya who at one point was the
only bioinformatician on this project
and she was basically given a lifetime's
worth of work with the amount of data we
were generating until Sarah alings group
took over Dana helped me with some of
the um uh graphs and I'd like to thank
Paul and ncy from pack and Elma for
inviting me here to talk today and last
but not least Tracy whose kindness and
patience has been immense over the last
few weeks thank you so I'm now handing
over to
philli uh what I'm going to describe you
today is a new technological
approach that will allow
us to actually uh generate imuno assays
for detection of uh imp plants
so why do we need imun assays for
plants actually we need them all over
the
place uh if the goal is actually to
create a new plant like
uh uh transgenic plant you start with
actually the gene Discovery and protein
expression so you will have to measure
that by using uh n
assay then you'll have to create the
plant in question so you'll have to do
imuno assays at every step to follow it
to prove that it
works then you would have to go to
regulatory so you have to prove to the
FDA it actually
works then in production you'll have to
prove to your uh manufacturing
Department that it actually works and
finally you'll have to prove to the
customer that it actually
works so the gold standard generally
used for imuno acids is a Liza it is a
wellestablished
technology but it has some
handicaps uh especially if you want to
go into Mass screening or mass testing
so I will present a new technology
called
alphaa which is an lier replacement
technologies that show some advantages
at this
level so the first part will be to
describe what is alala and how does it
work and in the second part I will
present examples of a genetically
modified plants in which we are able to
detect the introduced
proteins
so when you what is Alpha and the basis
it is a bead based
technology you have two beads the blue
Dona bead and the red except
bead these beads can be brought together
by molecular interaction between
partners that are fixed on
them uh the goal here for example would
be the detection of an antigen by uh
Partners A and B when they are brought
together upon excite ition of the Don be
with uh infrared
laser chemicals into the Don be will
generate a Quantum state of oxygen
called singlet
oxygen this will then diffuse to about
200 nanom to penetrate the
accepted in the accepted there are
chemicals that will react with singlet
oxygen to actually generate light and
that light is the output you are going
to measure so two important things to
note here first of all this is an
amplification techniques for each speed
there are thousands of molecules of
singlet oxygen that can be generated and
there are thousands of chemicals in a
single accept that can receive the
singlet oxygen and generate photons so
you can get many photons from one
interaction the second thing to note is
that the single oxygen can diffuse up to
nanom while this may look small this
allows Alpha to measure about any
biological entity uh you can want to
detect from very small molecules like
amino acid or nucleotides up to uh very
large proteins such as igms or even Viro
particles so how is alal actually
analyza replacement technology it is
actually very similar on the left what
you have is the classical Eliza system
that will be so to detect nonn
analyes and the bottom of the plate in
green you have a capture antibody that
is bound to the plate this will bind the
analy uh that red that green squarish
thing it will then be detected by the
blue antibody which is called a
detection
antibody this antibody can be detected
by other Moes in that case it is bated
and recognized by subin the subin is
labeled to an enzyme that will convert a
substrate present in the Eliza mix to a
color molecule so you actually measure
the color this is where the
amplification happens because this
enzyme can convert several molecules
substant the conversion is actually
straightforward the
IG uh used for capturing instead of
being bound to a plate is bound to the
acceptable
be the analy is recognized by that
antibody which is then recognized by the
blue uh detection antibodies and instead
of having saavan and label with an
enzyme you have the Don which is also
labeled with
subtab so then the sing oxygen can go
between the two bead and generate the
signal the amplification coming like I
described before from the fact that you
can have many Photon generated that one
be
pair on this slide you show that
creating bead uh especially the acceptto
bead is actually quite
simple uh you don't need complex
chemical interaction or uh activation
of the antibody or anything is just a
mix and weight technology you just put
antibody along with the acceptor bead
and a mild reducing agent to obtain an
Aman bond between the antibody and the
bead this allows you uh easy
reproducible a mild uh treatment that
doesn't require much
antibodies but has also the advantage of
giving you a stable C valent bond that
will resist any kind of biological
Matrix you can put in there so there's
no risk for example of the antibody
leeching out of the plate if I were to
use a large amount of
detergent so there are actually two
formats then you can use to do your
elizer uh the typical one on top that
has been privil to describe is called
the sandwich ACD which is a signal
generation assd the more analy you have
the more the beads are brought together
and the more signal you actually get
unfortunately in some cases you may want
to detect a very small
molecule so in that
case uh the molecule is too small to
having two antibodies be able to bind it
at the same time so what you do is
actually you have a label prob which is
analyed can bu directly to the Don be
and is recognized by the accept
so if you have a analy in your sample it
will compete that interaction so you
have a signal decrease acid this can be
useful to detect things like amino acid
or
nucleotides but when uh you're detecting
proteins in 99% of the case it will be
the sandwich acid will be
used so now let show you the protocol
compared to aner as you can see
extremely simple you just add your analy
into the wells of
microplate you add your acceptor bead
and your biot related
antibody or uh in analyed terms your
capture detection antibody you incubate
for about 1 hour in most highs you'll
have your donor beads you'll incubate
for about 30 minutes in most essays you
then excite and read the signal
as you can see here this ass is right
fast uh including pipetting time and
creating your dilution it will take
about 2
hours and as you can see also it is an
mogeneous
asset so there is no uh wash stab in any
portion of the assay so you gain on time
and I'll show you discuss a little later
uh you also uh ease up your
automization so now that we have
presented Alpha we're going to see it at
work in plant
assets so the goal here was actually to
create an assay that could detect a
transgenic
cotton uh these cotton
seeds uh were modified by the
introduction of a gene from basil to
gensis which is a protein that actually
kills insects that will try to eat the
seeds or the other portion of the
planet uh there are several
variants uh two here are mention cry1 a
and Cry 2 a that will be the target of
our assays but there are several other
variants so the current assay is
actually a 96 well plate
Eliza uh that uses one seed to do the
acid it also provides a qualitative
answer so there is a protein present or
there's no protein
present so the request here was actually
to replace the Eliza with alphaa for
several reasons first of all uh the goal
was to reduce the price of
passing was to introduce the potential
of actually multiplexing at least two of
the
proteins and increase the trut by
increasing the use of Automation and
actually moving to smaller well plates
like 384 well plates so the trooper can
be massively
improved so we
actually uh took a look at it and
decided this would be
feasible so then we started to work on
it uh uh top left you have the actual
assay itself which is a typical sandwich
assay between an acceptable and a boled
antibody in that case uh the icid
described here would cry to
a so what we did was actually use
commercial
antibodies against the acid so on the
right you have a graph when we tested
various antibody pairs dete
and capture
antibodies by either labeling the
antibody to beads or balting it and
trying to find a good pair we actually
found two
possibilities one was to use the same
antibody uh on both sides the other one
was a mixed pair of
anybody uh as you can see the third
anybody didn't give any signal and was
rejected so for technical reason we
prefer to have two different
antibodies so we use the two connection
antibodies to actually generating
asset the Second Step uh lower left is
actually optimization of the AET there
are ways to tweak the protocol to try to
improve
sensitivity and uh signal output of the
assd so what we did here if you remember
the protocol instead instead of mixing
the two antibodies and the analy we
mixed only one antibody with the analy
incubated then we haded the second
antibody then we haded the Don be the
result are blue we call it the three
step assd and as you can see if we use
that acid the signal is significantly
increased and the sensitivity is
increased by three
tons so this essays were done with Rec
protein but what they show us is that we
can actually make an assay we do cover
the need for yes or no we can have a
very nice hesy window showing the
presence of the protein and we went a
step even further because by using the
standard Cur show here we can actually
measure the amount of protein in each
seat so the next step was actually to
see if we can do it in
seeds so we used a very easy seed
extract protocol which is simply grind
one seed or about 90 mg of seed are
treated with an extraction buffer for an
overnight and then C aut to remove uh
seed particles and test your
protein as you can see we have very neat
assays the high bars are actually the
seed that were transfected with Cry 2 a
uh the very small bars on the left are
the ones that were not treated with cry
2A we call the wild type seeds so you
can see we have a very good uh
difference
between uh the actual treated seed and
the wild typ
seeds uh the tree graph represent three
different type of extraction buffer
confirming that very very soft and very
easy extraction buffers can actually be
used uh the lower left is the most
interesting because that uh extraction
buffer is also the acid buffer we use
for alphal Lia so you don't need to
introduce special buffers or special
extraction
condition so now that we have a
functional assay we were asked if we
could Multiplex this assay so we decided
to test it the multiplex process is
actually to introduce more and more
acceptor beads into the aets here you
have an example that we can do with our
instrumentation and Technology to do a
duplex you have your blue uh don be in
the center you have two different B
related
antibodies and you have two different
acceptto the combination here will be
able to detect two different
analyes so in the same well in the same
assays you can have two standard curve
and two detection of two different
analytes allowing you to double your
output and actually measure things like
ratios of protein one versus protein
2 so we actually applied it to
seeds so the goal here was actually to
detect two proteins Cry 1 a and Cry 2
a uh in the same well in the same
assays so here we actually tested two
different uh new uh dup speeds the UTB
is actually a combination of 545 and 615
nanometer emission the u e USM is
actually uh 615 and 6
42 uh nanometer uh
experiments so here you can see in
the solid blue in both graphs you'll
have Cry 2 which is detected by the 615
beads the solid bars are the seeds that
were transfected with c 2 the open uh
boxes were the one that are the one type
so as you can see you get again a very
nice icing window and a clear
differential between the two with high
sensitivity in
uh in the red bars you get cry one uh
AB again the solid markers indicate the
transected
seed the open markers indicate the wild
High
so in a single asset you were able to
measure the two different components at
the bottom you have a summary of the SB
present so you can see that in both
cases you can have assd Windows of 50
and over that will give you a very clear
response to the presence of the
particles in
question with high sensitivity High
selectivity and high efficiency
so this was an example of one target as
you can see uh this is a site that
described many sorts of transfected
seeds that are available so it shows
that there are many targets where this
technology could be
applied uh and this is actually a
confirmation By Us and other customers
that the output and the efficiency of
the technology uh is actually present we
can show for
example uh that one technician can
actually uh almost
decate uh the amount of sample we can
actually
process sensitivity is higher sample
volume is significantly lower up to 20
times lower than the concentration
needed in
Eliza and the data can actually be
obtained in about two hours which allow
you to create at least three or four
different assd runs per
day so in summary Alpha has proven uh uh
very applicable to plant protein
technology it is extremely
versatile uh it can detect various
ranges of affinity with molecular weight
it can easily be miniaturized all the
assay that was shown to you were done in
a 384 well plate if you want to further
miniaturize and go to
1536 all you have to do is D is divide
every addition volume by four and simply
add directly to the
plate uh they can use with complex
biological matrixes such as plant
extract in that case seeds extract or we
also did it with weaves or other parts
of the plant
extracts uh the conversion from
Eliza to alphaa is extremely
straightforward and the technology is
cost-saving and very productive the
endon time is diminished especially
because there's no need for washing the
plates or things like that it consumes
very low amounts of any body and also
very low amount of sample and we also
show it was uh capable of
multiplexing so I'd like to thank the
people that actually took care of this
project and generated these very
interesting data application specialist
lyy
Nelson uh senior application specialist
Steve ER and uh the manager of this
assay Vincent
D so now I'm going to uh send the uh the
speaker to our moderator with
Bunch we'll take over uh at this
step good morning ladies and gentlemen
uh this is dwesh
parihar I'll be talking about
application of high throughput
genotyping for Market assisted selection
in plan
breing uh this is something which uh is
quite useful in almost all types of
trait
introgression or any Gene linked to a
marker interation of such a
gene uh so uh as I mentioned earlier uh
that uh genotyping forms a very
important component
in uh mon assisted selection and
accelerated back Crossing when we are
going for transfer of GM or non GM trade
from the donor genotype uh to to to any
recurrent parent or parents of the uh uh
existing hybrids
uh so uh and and this is done in many
different ways uh starting from
uh uh using SSR markers and before that
it was rflps and so on uh in this slide
uh this is a typical uh backcross
program for trade introgression which is
used in majority of the uh trade
integration programs whether in uh seed
industry or in public sector um
institutes uh where uh a gene here in
this particular case it's a dominant
gene uh needs to be transferred to a
recipient
parent and you make a cross get F1 carry
out for ground
selection and then um select the uh
plants which have uh gen of course it
will be in the heterozygous condition
cross it again with the with the recip
recipient parent or recurrent parent and
you go on till uh bc3 and after that uh
this proen can be selfed to obtain bc3
F2 where uh using foreground selection
one can select for the uh plants having
the gene in homozygous condition and so
on uh during this whole process if we
see foreground selection is carried out
to select for the presence of gene or
trait of
interest and background selection is
carried out to select plants carrying
higher uh genomic component of the
recurrent
parent and uh this is where it becomes
very critical to select plants in each
generation uh the plants having highest
uh genomic component based on genotyping
which can be carried out by SSR based
markers now or snip based
markers and this really accelerates the
whole process of uh back Crossing uh so
conventionally if we
see uh this slide that conventionally if
we compare traditional back cross versus
Mar assisted accelerated back Crossing
program in the traditional back cross
usually uh up to back cross n generation
uh carried on and uh still uh we see
uh it's not really complete recovery of
the recurrent parent genome on the other
hand if we are using um marker assisted
selection uh in that case by bc4 that is
the backcross generation 4 we already
have plans having Almost 100% uh
recurrent parent genome and this is what
is required for a successful backcross
program where Gene integration is being
carried out and in terms of time if you
see the long cycle almost uh lasting
more than 3 years if we are doing in a
conventional way and on the other hand
if it is done through marker assisted
selection it Tak uh the the whole
program can be converted in a shorter
time close to 2 years which is almost
half of the time which is required in
the tradition
method and if uh we are using Mar
assisted breeding uh for integration of
one to two
genes uh and if there are one to two
recurrent parents where the genes are
being transferred then the conventional
method not really conventional method
but the method which was used uh I would
say 5 to 7 years back uh involved
carrying out foreground selection using
uh uh PCR with the specific primers for
the gene or genes uh of Interest select
the plants carrying uh the genes and
Carry Out background selection by
genotyping using SSRS on such
plants and uh select the best plants uh
from this generation if we see this
whole process um uh of course 7 to eight
years back this was okay but if somebody
has to carry out this process now uh it
it looks quite quite lengthy and and
cumbersome because uh the first thing is
that uh reading of these gels if there
are just few gels it is easy to read um
uh for for the background selection but
when it comes to uh sorry uh for the
foreground selection when it comes to
background selection it becomes even
more difficult because number of gels
that one has to read is quite high if uh
on an average if a scientist is using UH
60 uh SSR primers uh for
genotyping uh then then it becomes
almost UH 60 agos gels to be read
manually and then compile the data and
run it through the software to generate
uh genetic diversity and tend to select
uh the plants which are closest to uh
recurrent parent
so uh this is uh that is the whole uh
process which I have explained in this
slide where if we are carrying out
ingression of one to two
genes in uh one to two recurrent parents
so if you look at one gene for
foreground selection and if you carry
out uh PCR based selection then out of
100 50% of the plants they turn out
positive for the genain
then uh when we move on to the
background selection on an average if we
use 60 SSR markers for background
selection and in two segregating
population then this numbers almost
become 100 plans and then it is tested
with 60 SSR primers then it becomes
6,000 PCR
SAS now we see the numbers are
multiplying and to run this this many
PCR reactions uh we need at 24 PC U if
we are running 24 PCR reactions for AG
gel it becomes almost 250 gels for data
analysis and uh the output of that data
will result in selection of PL so
manually reading uh such a large number
of shells uh is cumbersome and and it
leads to certain errors uh during manual
data
calculations so uh overall the the
handling of samples in this way is is
messy uh because at times we end up with
Agro shells with which are either
smiling or
frowning uh and that results in error in
uh reading those that kind of AG CHS and
it comes to data analysis again it is
time consuming and when it is done
manually it's prone to
errors the other important part uh in a
back cross program is uh the isolation
of DNA
uh doing the PCR getting the results and
the flowering time of that crop so
usually it happens that if we have a
lengthy combersome process then it
becomes difficult to match the flowering
time of crops and then at times there
are delays in carrying out
crossing the other uh problem associated
with this is that few populations can be
handle thus uh it severely restricts
utility of mar assisted selection when
we are working with with uh large scale
application hence what we need really is
a rapid way of
genotyping uh of large number of samples
several segregating populations can be
handled
simultaneously that is what is the
demand of a
successful uh back Crossing program
where marker assistant selection
actually accelerates the whole
process and and makes the whole uh whole
process quite quite easy to
handle and when we talk about the rapid
genotyping uh again there are several
options available uh compared to agaro
Shell uh there is a possibility of using
uh systems which are more uh automated
uh taking less time uh and uh so uh the
whole process uh again for Rapid
genotyping would involve isolation of
DNA from large number of
samples then a good uh appropriate PCR
setup to generate amplicons for
analysis and followed by uh setup for
rapid reproducible and automated
analysis of
amplicons uh which uh in in the
conventional way is AG gel and followed
by
uh appropriate software tools for large
scale data acquisition anal is and
presentation of results in a simple
readable form so that uh the the the
researchers at the field level can can
read it easily understand it easily and
Carry Out selection of plans for for
back
Crossing and uh one of the uh one of the
uh simple method which we have used uh
in our lab to speed up this whole Pro
process of marro assisted selection in
in a practical uh breeding
program uh in in a seed industry uh I
work for hybrid seed industry where uh
uh Mar assist selection is quite common
for different types of introgression
programs uh whether it is introgression
of trans genes or introgression of uh
genes linked to a marker stacking of
genes linked to marker so all these
things we do almost uh on daily basis
and uh there we found that making a
shift from agell electroforesis to a
microfluidic uh chip capillary electr
fores is really helped uh in speeding up
the whole process and and uh carrying
out the analysis in a very timely manner
so uh eventually uh what we learned from
this was that uh uh it it is critical to
have a have a a nice very efficient
system uh at the stage of
genotyping and this uh and and also uh
the system which we used uh which is
based on microfluidic chip capillary
electroforesis which is essentially a
miniaturization of uh what do you call
sort of agos shell but everything uh is
is miniaturized and and automated so um
and and the instrument software they
control the movement of fluids through
this Optical
channels and the uh the the
the with the help of laser the movement
of DNA bands is detected and
recorded so uh essentially this system
takes over uh the electroforesis and
data acquisition part and uh the system
with this kind of system one can use a
96 well uh PCR plate and if we have want
to shift to higher throughput then
definitely it is amenable to a 380 whe
for well plate format also only
difference is that in this kind of
situation we need PCR machines whose
block is also in 380 well
format um so uh once the once the uh uh
the VCR reactions are run through this
kind of microfluidic system
um and and it it is it is fairly uh
simple uh after the PCR reaction you
just take your plate uh take off the uh
the cover and put it on the uh stand and
just uh switch it on switch on the
software and and if you are interested
you can stand in front of the Monitor
and see what is happening but uh after a
couple of runs uh then you realize that
it works on its own there is no need to
stand there and walk watch so
essentially you put the things there and
and just go and do something else
whatever uh whatever you have to do
whether data analysis from previous
experiments or
so so in this in this slide uh this is a
representative electrogram from uh one
of the population where it is showing
polymorphic
Al uh and and as you can see uh the size
difference between this Al and and this
one this is a larger Al compared to this
one so this is a polymorphic Al which
can be easily uh detected uh with this
kind of system otherwise if if I just
see compare it with the ago shell then
probably all these three ales may be
difficult to uh differentiate on agaro
shell uh compared to a microfluidic
system and and uh and this kind of
results are pretty easy to uh read and
and analyze so here is this example of a
polymorphic Al if you move on to the
next uh slide uh this is an example of
monomorphic Al so there is no
polymorphism between uh these two
samples and uh the third example I have
taken is is a missing Al so you see here
we have three
ales uh in and in this sample we have
only one Al present so uh uh the the
best part of this system the data uh
what do you call the data acquisition
and its analysis is so good that even
the minor differences which would be
otherwise uh missed would be missed in
an agro Chell can easily be detected
thus it results in higher number of data
points uh per uh per uh PCR Primal that
we are using for
genotyping and uh
uh uh it is easy to analyze the data
which is coming out of uh this kind of
uh DNA
analysis uh and uh apart from these
electrograms uh the system also
generates virtual gels uh which can be
easily used uh to compare the results
which are there on the electrogram
versus a virtual gel
image uh actually when we started using
this system
we ran couple of uh uh PCR Reactions
where samples were run on um on the micr
fluing system and also on the agos shell
and at times we found that the level of
detection in case of
microfluidic system uh it can detect um
TNA bands in nanogram quantities which
at times becomes difficult when we are
using AG
chel so overall uh the results generated
by such a system are are I mean we are
quite happy and initially were quite
impressed because it made our life
easy uh coming on to uh the data data
part that the system acquires data uh
from the uh DNA samples being analyzed
and this can be easily exported from the
of course we are using
lcgx so uh from there the data can be
exported to Excel sheet uh just by click
of a uh of a one
button and from here uh you can easily
see uh that what what is happening that
what kind of ales are there like if this
is an example where we have these uh
four eles uh which
are which are there and they are not
showing uh they're not showing any uh
polymorphism and also also it shows uh
the concentration of DNA uh in the in
the in the uh virtual gel so you can see
that it can detect almost 1.8 nog even
less than 1 nog very
easily so once this data is transferred
to Excel sheet then by using some tricks
uh these can be converted into a binary
table where uh we have our recurrent
parent the donor parent and uh the El
which are detected by the system and you
fill in this sheet uh transfer to any
software we use ntcs PC uh for further
analysis and I select back best uh plans
for back Crossing in the Next Generation
this whole process is again a very
simple one uh one person can can do I
don't know maybe
uh four to five segregating population
in a day uh anal of the data coming from
four to five populations in a
day and eventually we end up with the uh
with a dorram we we use dorram but there
can be several other outputs uh the data
can be used to generate several
different types of outputs we found that
for the people who are working in the
field for them this is quite easy to
understand that here is my recurrent
parent and these three plants are the
ones which are closest to my recurrent
parent so these plants are the ones
which the which the person at the field
level will select and Carry Out Back
Crossing with theur
par and and this whole process uh is is
uh very convenient because time taken to
do the whole analysis is now short and
uh very easily we can match the
flowering time of different
populations and uh and and do things in
time
so coming to uh towards the end of my
presentation on on the on our shift from
Agro shell to microfluidic system so in
terms of if you do a comparison between
agos gel based genotyping and micr flow
based genotyping so initial investment
uh is low on the other hand uh for a
system like this it is
moderate uh data points output is
moderate is high uh this is because uh
in ag cell BAS genotyping genotyping
system we are not able to detect all the
Al and so we end up with lesser data and
which may result in errors in the final
analysis uh cost for data point is low
in case of agros and it is moderately
high but it very well gets compensated
by the efficiency of the whole system of
course if you look at the time it takes
a longer time compared to uh this kind
of system manual intervention over here
is minimal you put the plate in the
system and uh switch it on and you can
go and have a cup of coffee or or uh you
can uh do something else more important
things to
handle and as I as I mentioned earlier
in terms of efficiency so the cost per
data point uh very well gets compensated
by the high efficiency of this system
high overall efficiency
and also another very critical part is
that when we are working with agros
shels the gel images we have to store uh
as data and they take large amount of
space in the server uh versus uh very
small size uh files generated by a
microfluidic system uh the one which we
are using is lcgx and and where small
size files can be large large number of
such files can be stored uh without
taking much space from the
server uh of course if is important and
and there no such chemical uh the users
are not exposed to any toxic chemicals
like ethum bromide which are used in
conventional
Ag and there's another important part is
that uh this whole system can be
automated uh if if uh uh there are large
number of samples then you can add more
than
one more than one lcgx system and
a robot can be attached which can which
can do uh transfer of the plates from
PCR machine uh to the lcgx system and
then it becomes a fairly uh simple
automated system and of course uh there
are other options for automation which
I'm not going to uh discuss now but
overall uh my um experience with this
system was quite good I mean definitely
starting shifting from my gel to this
kind of system is makes lot of
difference and and uh I I'm quite happy
with this
system um with this uh I think uh I
would like to say thanks thanks for your
patience and listening to uh my
experience of having the shift from agos
Shell to a microfic system especially
for genotyping and of course it can be
used for many other
applications uh even even uh it can be
used for RNA
analysis uh with with certain changes
even proteins can be analyzed so so it's
it's a multi-utility system thank you
very
much and now open the question and
answer session uh the first question we
have coming in gain is for you um for
our remote audience if you do have
further questions there are several that
came through during the course of the
webinar but if if you do have further
questions please feel free to post them
in the question and answer box which at
least on my environment is the Blue Bar
Box in the lower left hand side of uh
your environment so gain first question
for you um involves the
scaffolding uh and the question is would
the viewer is familiar with the pack bio
system would the p biosystem fit your
workflow for the scaffolding and I'll
pass control over to you to
answer
okay is it oh there's me again um I
think uh in the very early days um uh we
considered the pack bio but I guess the
throughput just wasn't um uh great
enough and I think there was some pack P
work done but
um uh just you with the longmate pairs
to to build a scaffolding you you can
generate so much data with so little um
uh reagent and sequencing capacity and
um um we went with a long mate pair I
mean the I think Darren's uh latest
longmate pair run was 12 pools of 384
you just couldn't get that kind of data
with the pack bio I don't
believe has that answer your
question oops I have to P it back
to
thank you gain um the second question is
also uh for you GNE and it's somewhat
related uh the question came in Also
regarding the scaffolding and it's about
the scaffold sequence um and the
question is as follows so following your
workflow each scaffold sequence needs to
be placed among the others the question
is how do you plan to merge merge the 6K
assemblies into a single assembly and
what tools are you using to do
so I'm not really
a oh did you get all that
um I'm not really a bi informatician I
don't really know in my head what I
would imagine is that you get all the
backs and stick them into a massive
assembler and um put them together but I
don't really know and I spoke to the
person who um asked that question and
I'm going to um uh look into it further
I I can let you know the answer if if
you know I'm so what's the word far
removed from the btics that uh I I
really don't know how that would happen
I'm
sorry
uh pass full
control
yeah okay thank you gain uh the next
question incoming is for you Philipe
it's about the the alpha technology in
your presentation uh the question is in
Multiplex Alpha how can we assure the
higher selectivity of the an B is used
to detect two different proteins and not
getting interference or multiple
attachment of the two proteins to one
antibody okay to answer that question I
didn't show the data for Simplicity but
every assay is first done
individually so I would generate one
assay for protein one and one assay for
protein two and then I would try to
crossmatch them like use the assay for
protein one against protein 2 and use
the assay for protein 2 against protein
one if I were to get any signal out of
these Cross Match assays I would simply
dismiss that as unworkable and try to
select other antibodies that have more
selectivity
okay thank you Philipe uh the next
question also is in regards uh to Alpha
uh the question is is the alpha Eliza
quantitative how many analytes have been
tested successfully in your Multiplex
system
um so we're talking about two questions
here the first question is actually yes
Alpha is
quantitative because uh as I showed on
some of the earlier slides when I
presented the planned results we can
actually see that uh we are basing a
result on the standard curve that was
done in the same Matrix as for the ass
so you can easily plug the signal you
get from your seeds on that standard
curve and actually measure the exact
amount protein present in your seed
sample uh the second question how many
duplexing asdes we do we did several of
them I would say we have uh concrete
data for about half a dozen but we are
working on
more uh every day now and we should
should have a more complex list uh the
ones we did involve several different
domains including plants uh
animals uh
Biotherapeutics and pure biochemical
assets okay Philip thank you very much
uh the next question is
uh back to gain and it's about some cost
figures for your workflow and the
question is what is the approximate cost
of each back from your
workflow okay um So currently the cost
is 5 per back from uh back to
sequence
um we did have
a something in mind to get to 4 pounds
um to do that because we originally were
a Sanger sequencing lab here and uh we
used to sequence backend sequence just
the ends for £4 and I don't know why
that's become the sort of Target but it
was about 78 and it's come down to now
about5 per back so it's it's quite
cheap
thank you GNE and in similar fashion uh
Philipe there's a a Cost question for
Alpha and the question is um I guess
twofold
um are the costs per sample for Alpha
lower than standard Eliza and two what
steps allow if it's lower the cost to be
lower with Al than
Eliza okay to answer the first part of
the question is yes the costs are
usually lower than for a regular
Eliza the cost reduction actually CES
from several portion of the uh
technology first of all you save on
time uh for by neglecting the needs for
uh things like blocking steps and wash
assays so you save on the FTE portion of
your assay you also save on issues like
uh your
Plastics like uh you need much less tips
for example if you don't do wash assays
and S you can miniaturize you don't
needan as many plastic
plates finally the amount of anti
bodybody needed con at your
acceptabilities and do your actual
assaying the bated antibody are
extremely low we're talking amounts here
ranging in the single
nanomolar range which would take uh
probably indicate uh in your well a
couple of picograms of
antibody so with a regular assemble of
anybody like 100 microgr
you can run literally thousands and
thousands of essays which is not
necessarily the case with
Eliza and the next question is uh right
back to you Philip uh the question
is how will you relativize your data
once you get beond beyond the alphal lia
and how much background do you get
compared to a normal
Eliza so uh the background issue is
actually something you can
control uh background is actually
extremely low because the chances of two
be Crossing each other randomly compared
to the volume of an ay well is extremely
small uh so there's no also very little
risk of anything sticking to the beads
in some cases you may have to
optimize uh the assay to guarantee that
but usually it is not really an
issue okay another another question that
pertains to the alpha technology and
it's in regards to uh duplexes phip the
question being is there a capacity for
two duplexes and how does this work in
the alpha system if there indeed is uh
capacity for multiple
duplexes okay uh we haven't tested
really so far had
uh more than uh one
duplex uh in act in a single well uh we
have done duplexing in a single well uh
if you want to add even more
combinations then you would probably
need to uh like a
Triplex then uh this would probably mean
I say
optimization and special protocol for
reading but it is something we can
easily work out
uh there's no actual technical obstacle
to doing it it would just need uh a
slightly different protocol than the one
you use for simple and
duplexing okay thank you very much I
want to again extend a hearty thanks to
our speakers today uh f Roby and GNE
Bennett um I hope you've enjoyed this
session as a remote audience as much as
we enjoyed uh putting it on and uh also
hope you look for future content from
labroots and and perk and Elmer so we're
at the top of the hour uh we're going to
close our session now thank you again
all for attending and please look uh for
future content in this webinar format
thanks we'll be signing off
now